This is my concern.
If you want to have long hair,
great. If you like your long hair, amazing.
But don't put your identity into it,
because the only thing that should be defining you
is your relationship with Jesus Christ.
Jesus. Jesus is it,
dude, that's it.
There's. If you're finding your worth in your value
and anything other than Jesus,
then that is an idol in your life.
And it was for me for a time.
I remember being in high school and absolutely
loving the attention that my hair brought me.
Actually, most of my life,
because I didn't really cut my hair until I was
way out of high school.
I love the attention that my hair brought me, and it.
I took such pride in it.
And then when I had my brain surgery,
my hair started to fall out.
It was extremely.
It was a rough season for me.
It was very difficult.
But I had almost an identity crisis,
because it's like
this thing makes me special,
and if I don't have this thing,
then what do I have?
Well, here's the good news.
That's not who I am.
My hair was not who I am.
Jesus defines me.